por la pandemia en nuestra cita
culturales en casa y es desde ese lugar
con una escena violenta que arranca la
serie del momento patria de inicio se
diría que responde a españa y eso 60
años de conflicto vasco con el grupo
terrorista eta pero patria es sobre todo
un lugar de terror que tras el fin de la
lucha deja un espacio vacío que no se
sabe si llenarse con perdón o más rabia
más eta está ahí la realidad está ahí
pero el dolor y sus consecuencias son
protagonistas canalizado las vidas
ficticias creditores y miren la primera
representa el dolor de ser víctima y la
necesidad de cerrar heridas la segunda
el dolor de perder a un familiar que en
muchos casos tenía un ideal nacionalista
pero no lo cultivó ideológicamente hasta
ir a la cárcel
queremos notificarle a usted su familia
y todos sus bienes son objetivo
operativo derecha
buena persona y un padre de familia era
un opresor
m
en casa
de su madre siempre piensan en un
conflicto cercano con bandos y verán el
porqué de las críticas nosotros
compramos sólo una y es que no se hable
euskera mostrando su riqueza lingüística
pese a ello aitor gabilondo logra una
atmósfera universal que no juzga y hasta
supera el libro de origen de fernando
aramburu que los actuales sean vascos es
el mayor acierto saben de qué hablan las
caracterizaciones y la ambientación por
épocas son de alucine pero patria no
sería igual sin las matriarcas elena
irureta y han en cámara in han trabajado
juntas durante 30 años y si bien han
hecho comedias se dejan las tripas en
una tristeza que no es disfraz
compruébenlo en estos ocho capítulos de
la primera serie es mío europe
en simultáneo en 60 países que ofrecerá
hacer su búsqueda que cantará en euskera
ya te respondo
y ahora
dos buenas razones nos llevan al cine la
primera vez que cannes y tendrá festival
sacándose en la espina del certamen que
no pudo celebrar en mayo solo durará
tres días de fines de octubre será una
mini edición pero condensar a los
cortometrajes seleccionados además de
cuatro títulos de la competencia oficial
entre ellos la georgiana beginning que
arrasó en san sebastián
mismo verbo para ya no estoy aquí
segunda buena noticia que logró 10
premios ariel coronándose como la mejor
película del cine mexicano reciente el
mérito es de fernando frías de la parra
que aborda la historia de ulises un
joven que en las colinas de monterrey
vive de lleno la contracultura colombia
de imagen chola y pasión por el baile y
la cumbia rebajada pero el narcotráfico
y la muerte de un hermano lo arrancan de
esa iniciación y lo obligan a oír al
queens neoyorquino donde poco a poco
tratar a su ves arraigo con otra
migrante un viaje de angustia y añoranza
en el que lo globalizado es hostil
cuando no se elige y se carga una
mochila identitaria muy propia la de
ulises está en netflix
y quién habla
que demorarlo salud para mi raza
bueno con todo gusto que realizó donde
los llama seca de nueva york
caray que internacional
[Música]
en inglés
sobre artes saben que los museos se
desviven por el espacio que los limita
exhibir entre un 7 y un 2 por ciento de
sus fondos pero el boymans gambón in
game de rotterdam le ha puesto solución
con un mega almacén que revelará al
público sus más de 151.000 obras por
primera vez un depósito verá la luz en
un edificio moderno que no solo
embellece por sus mil 664 paneles de
cristal sino que evitará inundaciones y
dispondrá de cinco zonas climáticas de
conservación es todo un parque de
atracciones del meta museo porque nos
dejará ver como los trabajadores
mantienen restaurant y conservan una
colección de siete siglos de historia un
deporte que ya buscan imitar el victoria
albert de londres y el louvre de parís
y con tu otra bonita cerramos la semana
el grupo español con presencia en
latinoamérica lanzó el tercer adelanto
de su próximo disco una composición que
aborda en la fuerza del amor y las
vueltas al revés que da la vida en su
caso un día tres chicos de barrio y al
otro músicos
mira
[Música]
mientras que entre un océano hace rato
que bailaba sandunguera argentina una
tea pelusso al borde del calambre título
de su nuevo álbum que es descarga
eléctrica y conexión con su más profunda
energía en sana sana ni el fmi y el
capitalismo se salvan
cuídense mucho y para ello la receta es
el cantautor británico michael kiwanuka
premio mercury es decir premio al mejor
álbum anglosajón de este loco 2020 por
su obra kiwanuka hasta pronto y muchas
gracias
[Música]